former president James bolsonaro
testified for almost three hours he's
being investigated by Brazil's federal
police for allegedly instigating the
January 8th attacks on government
buildings but he denied any wrongdoing
[Applause]
bolsonaro has strongly condemned these
attacks and any attempt against Brazil's
democracy
on January 8th bolsonaro supporters
stormed the presidential Palace Congress
and the Supreme Court they called on the
military to house president Ruiz Silva
who had taken office a week before
bolsonaro is being accused of laying the
grounds for the riots by repeatedly
making unfounded claims that Brazil's
voting system should not be trusted and
For Crying Out fraud even before Lula
defeated him in last year's election on
January 10th he shared a post on his
Facebook casting doubts on the Electoral
results his lawyers told the police he
had done so by mistake while recovering
from an intestinal occlusion in an
American Hospital in Orlando and while
being sedated
this post was published unintentionally
the proof is that as soon as he was
warned two or three hours later he took
the post down
bolsonaro flew to the United States in
December before ending his term since
his return to Brazil three months later
he has been the target of several
investigations but investigations are
far from over Brazil's Congress has just
announced it's launching a parliamentary
inquiry into the January 8th riots
Monica and archival Jazeera Brasilia
Brazil
still ahead here on Al Jazeera